hace ya muchos vídeos vislumbrábamos la
idea de representar como digamos una
función periódica como una suma infinita
de cosenos y senos con peso verdad y
también hicimos un buen trabajo
desarrollando las bases digamos en
términos de integrales definidas de
productos de senos y cosenos bueno aquí
no hay productos verdad pero tiene que
ver con senos y cosenos y con estos
empezamos a utilizarlos para poder
hallar fórmulas de los coeficientes de
nuestra serie de furia verdad entonces y
en realidad ya casi tenemos todo verdad
tenemos digamos la fórmula de acero y en
general tenemos una fórmula para a n
verdad y que tiene que ver justamente
con integrales de la función periódica
con cosenos muy bien entonces en este
caso en este vídeo lo que vamos a hacer
es digamos tratar de calcular los
coeficientes que acompañan a las
funciones senos muy bien entonces la
pregunta es cómo podemos hacerlo y lo
que vamos a hacer es una técnica muy
similar a cómo lo hicimos en el vídeo
anterior muy bien en donde vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados pero ahora en
este caso vamos a multiplicar por el
seno de nt muy bien vamos a multiplicar
por el seno de nt y por supuesto
multiplicamos de ambos lados por el seno
de nt seno de nt esto es bastante
bastante lento verdad pero pero no
importa al menos así nos damos una muy
buena idea de que estamos haciendo y por
supuesto como esto es una suma infinita
de términos pues vamos a multiplicar
todos y cada uno de estos términos de
nuestra suma infinita muy bien entonces
ya que hemos multiplicado por el seno de
nt ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
integrar sobre el intervalo de cero a
dos pi verdad y en realidad estamos
integrando en ese intervalo porque
nuestra función periódica
efe tiene periodo dos pi muy bien
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
integrar de cero a dos pi la expresión
de la izquierda y que corresponde a
integrar cada uno de estos términos
verdad porque
la integral de una suma de términos es
la suma de las integrales verdad
entonces vamos a integrar cada uno de
estos términos y por supuesto si te das
cuenta ya de una vez estoy sacando las
constantes a 0 a 1 v1 fuera de la
integral verdad entonces aquí será la
integral de 0 a 2 pi
respecto a t verdad la integral de 0 a 2
pi respecto a t ya casi terminamos la
integral de 0 a 2 pib respecto de t la
integral de 0 a 2 pi con respecto a p
muy bien entonces ahora ya que tenemos
esta expresión de aquí lo que podemos
ver es o más bien lo que vamos a hacer
es utilizar nuestras propiedades que ya
tenemos demostradas para empezar a
cancelar términos verdad por ejemplo
este primer término la integral del seno
de nt pues sabemos que tiene que valer 0
verdad la integral del seno de un entero
por t verdad con respecto a t y de cero
a dos pies cero para cualquier entero
cualquiera verdad entonces este término
de aquí se hace cero muy bien ahora bien
acá tenemos integrales de productos de
xenón con coseno y nosotros ya sabemos
que la integral del seno de cualquier
entero por t por el coseno de cualquier
otro entero por t con respecto a t y de
cero a dos pi vale cero verdad entonces
todos estos términos todos estos
términos se cancelan muy bien vamos a
ver qué pasa de este lado nosotros
tenemos integral de cero a dos pi de
productos de senos con distintos enteros
verdad y nosotros ya sabemos también que
la integral del seno del producto de
senos con distintos enteros nos tiene
que dar 0 excepto cuando tengamos el
mismo entero verdad entonces y que por
supuesto tiene que ser no nulo entonces
todos estos se van a cancelar y lo único
que nos va a quedar es justamente este
término verdad porque es justo cuando n
coincide con el otro pues digamos
coeficiente que acompaña
muy bien entonces esto en lugar de
digamos integrar el seno de emt por el
seno de nt en realidad lo podríamos
pensar como que estamos integrando el
seno al cuadrado de deporte verdad por
supuesto con respecto a t y nosotros ya
sabemos cuánto vale es verdad la
integral del seno cuadrado de un entero
por t de cero a dos pi con respecto a te
vale pi siempre y cuando el entero sea
no nulo es decir sea distinto de cero
pero en este caso es distinto de cero
así que todo esto que tenemos aquí vale
pi muy bien entonces en resumen que es
lo que tenemos en resumen del lado
derecho todo se canceló verdad
excepto el término este término que
sería b n por pi
vamos a poner esto tendríamos bn por pi
sería igual a lo que tenemos ahora del
lado izquierdo que es la integral de 0 a
2 pi de nuestra función periódica efe dt
por el seno de nt y todo esto por
supuesto lo integramos con respecto
dt y si queremos ser más explícitos y
quienes bn pues simplemente despejamos
verdad bn sería uno entre pi por la
integral de cero a dos pi de nuestra
función
efe dt por el seno tnt por el seno de nt
y esto lo integramos con respecto a t
muy bien entonces como te darás cuenta
esto fue bastante simple una vez que ya
conocemos las propiedades que habíamos
denunciado antes para las integrales
verdad en donde vamos a integrar
productos de senos y cosenos y usando
estas tres fórmulas que ya tenemos el de
acero
más bien la fórmula de acero la fórmula
de adn y la fórmula de bn utilizando
esas tres fórmulas podemos intentar
hallar el desarrollo en serie de furia
para la onda cuadrada